grew up in this working-class background
in the 60s
everybody worked all the men worked a
lot of the women worked because we were
a very working class area right so no
one didn't work when you don't work
there's no Canterbury every day is a
Saturday to be happy you've got to line
up your passions with your talents and
your inner needs passions are easy
because they're the things you think
about all the time are interested in
talents are easy because you just
discover you're good at things and you
know that but the inner drivers are much
more complex to work out and they last
forever they're the things that drove
you when you were 5 15 25 105 and I
found that I needed to be on a journey
so I needed to have been somewhere be
somewhere but going somewhere I need a
big risk of failure with pain attached
to it so just having a risk of failure
with no consequences doesn't mean
anything to me I need to be in a
constant place of Discovery learning new
things